[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 le
Japon s'est réveillé sous la menace de
la Corée du Nord Pyongyang attiré un
missile balistique de moyenne portée
au-dessus du pays c'est une première
depuis 2017 Tokyo a activé un système
d'alerte et a demandé aux habitants de
deux régions du nord du pays de se
mettre si possible à l'abri selon la
Corée du Sud c'était un tir de missile
de moyenne portée qui a volé sur une
distance de 4500 km à une altitude de
970 km il a survolé l'archipel vers
l'Est avant de tomber dans l'océan
Pacifique c'est où la qualifier ce tir
de provocation violent les principes
universels et les normes des Nations
Unies le conseiller américain à la
sécurité nationale Jackson a dit vouloir
réaffirmer l'engagement à toute épreuve
de son pays à ses alliés asiatiques
environ 28500 soldats américains sont
présents en Corée du sud du côté de
l'Union européenne c'est Charles Michel
qui a condamné avec force je cite une
agression injustifiée alors la stratégie
de la Corée du Nord de quel missile
parle-t-on quelle est l'étape d'après un
tir-nucléaire Kim Jong-un est-il
incontrôlable et bien on va en discuter
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés pardon excusez-moi Jean-Yves
Colin bonsoir spécialiste de l'Asie du
Nord à lésia à Center bienvenue dans le
débat en face de vous Pierre-Antoine
Daunay bonsoir journaliste à asialiste
et auteur de Chine le grand prédateur un
défi pour la planète aux Éditions de
l'Aube vous avez également dirigé
l'ouvrage qui sort au mois d'octobre aux
éditions du Cherche-Midi le dossier
chinois portrait d'un abîme au bord de
la Bible d'un pays au bord de la Bible
pardon nous avons avec nous en duplex de
Bruxelles le général Jean Vincent
Brisset bonsoir chercheurs associés à
l'Iris spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et de défense en Asie
justement merci d'être avec nous avant
d'en discuter je vous propose d'abord de
revenir justement en images sur ce tir
de missile nord-coréen au-dessus du
Japon
japonais du nord du pays ont été appelés
à évacuer on peut imaginer leur effroi
Antoine féno
il est presque 8 heures du matin au
Japon lorsque la télévision nationale
interrompt ses programmes
flash spécial selon le gouvernement
japonais la Corée du Nord aurait lancé
au moins un missile balistique il est
possible qu'il se dirige vers le Japon
le gouvernement demande à tout le monde
de rester à l'intérieur ou de trouver un
abri immédiatement
à travers le pays des sirènes
retentissent accompagnées d'un message
sans équivoque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une alerte relayée sur les téléphones
portables alors que les trains sont
brutalement stoppés en pleine voix
le missile traverse le nord du pays et
finit sa course dans l'océan Pacifique
l'alerte aura duré 20 minutes et
concernée de région du pays
j'habite dans un appartement et je n'ai
pas de cave donc quand ils ont dit de
s'abriter en sous-sol je ne savais pas
quoi faire
même s'il n'y a pas de sanction le
gouvernement doit être plus ferme
vis-à-vis de la Corée du Nord
s'il est bien plus puissant ça
m'inquiète vraiment
ce tir de missile au-dessus du Japon
c'est une première depuis 2017 une
provocation pour les autorités
japonaises avec 4500 km il aurait
également parcouru une distance record
pour un projectile nord-coréen
ils peuvent être inquiets les Japonais
oui ils sont naturellement inquiet et
puis mais ceci dit ce n'est pas
la première fois que les que des
missiles nord-coréens passent au-dessus
de du Nord du de l'île principale de du
Japon donc dans la région de tokou et
Kaido car depuis 1998 il y a eu avec
celui-ci cette cette passage si j'ose
dire dont trois avec préavis comme
autrefois c'était j'irai la règle entre
les deux pays et quatre sans préavis
donc là il y avait pas de préavis là il
y avait pas de préavis il y a aussi le
fait que les autorités japonaises ont
décidé d'activer un système
d'invertissement de warning qui est
utilisé d'ailleurs pour d'autres
catastrophes ce qui d'une certaine
manière mais les missiles nord-céréens
dans la catégorie des tremblements de
terre des tsunamis enfin des choses
qu'ils utilisent au Japon ne peut guère
ne peut résister en quelque sorte n'a
pas de moyen facile de d'arrêter donc et
comme d'habitude le gouvernement
japonais a protester à un défi qu'il
allait prendre des décisions qu'il
allait se concerter avec les ces voisins
sud-coréens avec les États-Unis ce qui a
été fait puisque
le secrétaire du Conseil national de
sécurité japonais à parler à Jacques
Sullivan les ministres des Affaires
étrangères des trois pays se sont
concertés les ministres des défenses des
trois pays se sont concernés il n'en
reste pas moins que sur ces bases là on
sait pas très bien quelle réponse on
peut faire face à ça on est un peu
devant une impasse
autrefois on aurait dit
mais prenons des sanctions
supplémentaires à l'ONU on va revenir
mais il se trouve que au mois de mai la
Chine et la Russie ont voté contre de
nouvelles sanctions donc il est probable
que si on dépose de nouvelles sanctions
je dirais sauf coup d'éclat en quelque
sorte elles ne sont pas votées
sur les réactions mais tout d'abord la
nature de cette menace Pierre-Antoine
Danet on a vu effectivement quand même
la stupeur des japonais on peut dire
aujourd'hui que la Corée du Nord menace
cette région et vous savez en fait pour
Kim Jong-un c'est la seule façon
d'exister aujourd'hui le langage c'est
le langage dans l'état voyou c'est le
troisième de la dynastie des clim et
s'il n'avait pas cette menace de missile
et cette menace nucléaire ça fait très
longtemps que le régime a été renversé
l'existentielle c'est existentiel et
c'est la seule façon d'exister et en
face le Japon
comprend de mieux en mieux cette
tactique et réagit de façon de plus en
plus claire aussi
l'intimidation du Japon c'est un peu
terminé le nouveau Premier ministre donc
il ne se sentent pas évidemment qui sont
peur évidents ils sont préoccupés et
pour la population du Nord du Japon
c'est c'est une menace constante l'île
d'okkaido on ne sait pas très bien où
celui-ci va pas atterrir est-ce que
c'est sur le sol japonais bien entendu
non mais malgré tout la crainte est là
mais le Premier ministre japonais a été
extrêmement ferme et son ministre de la
Défense encore plus le ministre de la
Défense a mis en garde la Corée du Nord
si il y a une autre fois il y aura une
réponse alors il n'a pas précisé la
nature de cette réponse on ne connaît
pas la nature de cette réponse et ça
aussi la question en général
Jean-Vincent brissait c'était
existentiel comme vient de le dire
Pierre-Antoine Daunay pour Kim Jong-un
justement de de balancer des missiles
comme ça balistiques et d'ailleurs quel
est ce sera intéressant que vous
reveniez exactement sur la nature de ce
missile pour l'instant on parle de
missile balistique est-ce que c'est un
missile hypersonique on a dit aussi que
la Corée du Nord en avait quelques-uns
alors c'est un c'est un missile
évidemment hypersonique les missiles
balistiques leurs caractéristiques
principales c'est de sortir de
l'atmosphère donc d'avoir une
trajectoire en cloche qui les mène très
haut en altitude avec un retour à très
grande vitesse sur la vers la terre
donc pour vous quelle est la stratégie
justement de Kim Jong-un est-ce que
c'est quelque chose d'existentiel ou
est-ce qu'il a une stratégie je dirais
plus profonde quelle menace il
représente dans la région alors
alors c'est quelque chose ça remonte pas
Kim jongle ça remonte à son père qui
nous ont il avait déjà commencé moi je
suis depuis 1994 il y a un jeu qui est
mené par la Corée du Nord vous parlez
dirigeants de leur coréen qui consiste à
faire peur à tout le monde à lancer des
programmes nucléaires puis des tests
nucléaires puis des tests balistiques et
échanger
l'arrêt ou des négociations contre des
fournitures il y a tout un programme
qu'il devait fournir de l'électricité
enfin de l'énergie et des usines
nucléaires non proliférantes à la Corée
du Nord en échange de d'un arrêt complet
des activités nucléaires potentialité
militaires tout ça c'est retombé à l'eau
et puis il y a eu des périodes un peu
plus dures un peu moins dures la Chine
n'a jamais réellement voulu sanctionner
la Corée du Nord sauf pendant la période
de l'administration Trump qui était une
période un peu particulière dans cette
saga qui se déroule depuis 1994 donc
Jean-Yves Colas connait justement un
moment vraiment d'escalade c'est vrai
que le général Jean-Vincent Brisset
parlait de ce moment où il y a eu un
moment entre Trump et Kim Jong-un ils se
sont vus à Singapour on s'en souvient
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est au
contraire dans une escalade que fait la
Chine ça ne l'ennuie pas ce qui se passe
il y a un peu un changement de cycle en
réalité puisqu'il y a eu effectivement
l'échec des négociations entre Kim
Trump est le président sud-coréen de
l'époque c'était Moon et puis le sujet
je dirais les deux sont rentrés dans
leur capitale sans qui est vraiment de
concrétisation de leur début des Bauges
d'accord et puis
il y a eu la campagne présidentielle en
Corée du Sud il y a eu un nouveau
président en Corée du Sud qui s'appelle
Youn sokyo qui lui a pris un peu le
contre-pied de Moon c'est à dire qu'en
Corée du Sud il y a aussi des phénomènes
d'alternance dans la approche de la
Corée du Nord il y a les présidents
souvent des démocrates ou des
progressistes qui sont partisans du
dialogue d'une certaine écoute d'une
certaine même bienveillance à l'égard de
la Corée du Nord et puis il y a les
conservateurs qui sont qui critiquent
les premiers au nom du langage de
fermeté on est aujourd'hui avec un
langage de fermeté ceci dit le président
Youn a cherché à ouvrir une nouvelle
voie en disant qu'il était prêt à
participer au redressement et au
développement économique de la Corée du
Nord sous réserve qu'il y ait un début
de discussion sur la dénucléarisation la
sœur de qui
donc qu'on connaît et qui a un langage
particulièrement fort a répondu ne
faites pas de rêve absurdes
on ne troque pas sa survie contre un
gâteau de maïs et c'est la politique que
tu ferme c'est la politique habituelle
je dirais de la Corée du Nord qui au
fond n'a jamais considéré le régime de
du Sud comme légitime et ne le considère
que comme des facto une marionnette aux
mains des États-Unis d'où la recherche
d'un dialogue avec les Etats-Unis or il
se trouve que depuis la queue monsieur
Biden est arrivé au pouvoir aux
États-Unis à l'évidence les tensions sur
la insulte ne sont pas la priorité du
président Biden mais en vous qu'elle
continue ses tensions Pierre-Antoine
Donnet la relation avec la Chine parce
qu'on va revenir justement sur la
réaction occidentale la Chine c'est
quand même l'Allier on peut le dire de
la Corée du Nord peut-être quoi sont
seuls et uniques vrai allié ou pas
comment se fait-il que la Chine
n'empêche pas son voisin de mettre en
place soviétique à l'époque Hélène
chinoise aujourd'hui l'économie
nord-coréenne qui est déjà à genoux
serait dans un marasme total là il y a
des famines mais ce serait bien plus
épouvantable mais vous avez raison
commerciaux avaient beaucoup baissé avec
le plus vide entre la Chine et la Corée
du Nord mais
pour répondre à votre question plus
directement bien sûr que la Chine et là
et il est clair que depuis très
longtemps déjà depuis Kim Jong-il et
maintenant qui me Jong-un les moyens de
pression de la Chine sur la Corée sont
peu de peu d'effets
Kim Jong-un est incontrôlable c'est le
commentaire a dit tout à l'heure mais
c'est la réalité de l'émission avec un
point d'interrogation voilà donc vous
dites c'est tout à fait et le moment
choisi pour ce tir de missiles n'est pas
du tout une coïncidence parce
qu'effectivement c'est à l'approche du
20e congrès et comme il a été dit tout à
l'heure aussi des élections à mi-mandat
aux États-Unis et donc le message en
direction de la Chine en disant nous
sommes là nous existons vous devez tenir
compte de nous et vous la Chine vous
devez rester à nos côtés nous aider et
ça vient aussi un moment de bascule
géostratégique planétaire ou les effets
les conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
redistribue toutes les cartes
géopolitiques et donc ce moment
absolument crucial pour la Corée du Nord
en fait il teste général Jean Vincent
Brisset vous êtes d'accord est-ce qu'il
vient de dire Pierre-Antoine Daunay
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de test qui
justement mis en place par Kim Jong-un
en envoyant ce missile effectivement 15
jours avant le fameux congrès du PCC
donc du Parti
communiste chinois et puis un mois avant
les élections de mi-mandat des
États-Unis
alors toute l'histoire de cette de ces
essais militaires aussi bien nucléaires
que balistique depuis 1994 sont des
tests à chaque fois il y a un test à
chaque fois il y a une provocation de la
part de la Corée du Nord et cette
provocation elle arrive souvent en début
des mandats présidentiels américains on
l'a vu avec Trump où il y a eu une
grosse provocation avec le test de 2017
et puis une réaction qui était pour une
fois tout à fait différent de
l'administration Trump par rapport à ce
qui avait été fait précédemment par
l'administration Obama qui au nom de la
patience stratégique a laissé la Corée
du Nord développée ses armements aussi
bien ses armes nucléaires que c'est que
ces missiles il y a eu une période
d'accalmie tentative de rapprochement
assez spectaculaire et qui a échoué
entre Trump et le président
nord-coréen et puis on retombe avec
l'administration Biden avec des éc
électorale avec des échéances politiques
et puis comme je viens de le dire tu
rentres donner des modifications
terribles sur le plan géopolitique donc
on refait un test pour voir qui est avec
qui la Chine qui avait accepté les
sanctions de sanctionner au niveau de
l'ONU la Corée du Nord à l'époque de
l'administration Trump ne le fait plus
maintenant et puis on voit sur
reconstituer un bloc antioxydantal qui
est pour le moment n'est pas formels qui
sont sans doute jamais formelles mais
qui prend de plus en plus d'ampleur au
fur et à mesure que les événements se
déroulent en Ukraine quel serait ce bloc
Jean-Yves Colin vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que vient de dire le général Jean
Vincent Brisset d'accord mais en fait ça
veut dire la Chine la Corée du Nord en
Ukraine a changé la question de la
péninsule coréenne il y a un certain
nombre de pays qui ont des vrais
intérêts il y a évidemment les deux
il y a le Japon parce que c'est le pays
je dirais ai par la Corée du Nord depuis
la guerre la guerre mondiale il y a la
Chine parce que c'est un comme on l'a
dit la force principale de cette région
et la puissance n'oublions pas non plus
même si c'est un petit peu un de grandes
sous la Russie les autres puissances
notamment les puissances européennes
sont actives parlent la France bénéficie
de son siège aux Nations Unies c'est un
atout mais ce ne sont pas les
principales parties prenantes donc cette
affaire nord-coréenne elle s'insère d'un
ensemble plus global avec dans le cas de
l'Asie une question qui a pris je dirais
le devant de la scène par rapport à
d'ailleurs à celle de Corée qui est la
question taïwanaise qu'est-ce qui va se
passer entre la Chine et les États-Unis
sur Taïwan quelles sont les réactions
que pourrait avoir le Japon par rapport
à cette affaire il faut pas il faut
savoir que
il y a des îles qui sont de souveraineté
japonaises qui se trouve à une centaine
de kilomètres permettent de Taïwan et
qui pose lui met un problème aucun
d'invasion maritime de la de l'île de
Taïwan par des forces chinoises et en
quoi est-ce liés au sujet de la Corée du
Nord
parce que tout ça est un je dirais est
un parti de une partie 2 de cartes dans
lequel chacun met un atout sur la table
retire une carte donc digérer les et il
y a un poisson
les États-Unis et la Chine parce que
c'est les deux grandes puissances qui
militairement peuvent vraiment
s'affronter avec des si le mot est mal
choisi mais disons des forces
supplétives qui sont le Japon et la
Corée du Sud ils sont pas négligeables
du tout je dirais mais ce sont des
forces supplétives un mot justement
avant de parler de l'Occident en
particulier Pierre Antoine Donnet en
quoi le conflit ukrainien a un impact
finalement là-bas aussi parce que j'ai
vu que la Russie a maintenant comme
allié effectivement la Corée du Nord
c'est le cas à pas dans les échanges
militaires manifestement Coréens du Nord
exportent des missiles c'est bien ça au
russe et puis également d'ailleurs dans
les sanctions qui ne votent pas
Nations Unies où ils soutiennent
finalement la Russie la Corée du Nord
un peu plus loin c'est un jeu de Go
c'est à dire un goban les possibilités
sont infinies et le but du jeu c'est
d'asphyxier l'adversaire alors on perd
on gagne si on surestime on perd si on
sous-estime on perd aussi donc il faut
trouver le juste équilibre et pour
revenir à l'Ukraine effectivement la
grande inquiétude je pense dans la
cervelle de Monsieur Kim Jong-un et de
sa sœur c'est de voir les conséquences
pour la Russie et derrière elle la Chine
parce qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui que la
Chine a bien sûr toujours hésité sur le
parti à prendre faire cause commune avec
la Chine ou non c'est impossible de
faire évidemment de faire cause commune
avec les États-Unis qui est le véritable
ennemi du qui communiste chinois mais en
même temps la Chine a évolué ces
dernières semaines de façon très
frappante aujourd'hui non seulement il
est plus question du tout d'aide
militaire elle n'aura jamais lieu parce
que ce serait une ligne rouge mais aussi
sans le dire de façon explicite les
autorités chinoises condamne l'invasion
de l'Ukraine il le disent de façon
claire ce n'est pas explicite mais on ne
s'y trompe pas explicite du tout oui
mais le message est très clair et
derrière cela comme vous le dites bien
sûr il y a Taiwan mais il y a aussi la
Corée du Nord et donc encore une fois
l'axe Pékin Yang il est fragilisé alors
jusqu'où ça ira c'est la grande question
avec évidemment comme vous l'avez dit et
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure l'expert
militaire d'ailleurs tout ça il y a les
États-Unis avec un langage de fermeté
très clair avec Joe Biden qui est repris
aujourd'hui par le Japon et aussi par la
Corée du Sud alors justement on va les
écouter les premiers ministres japonais
le président sud-coréen c'était
justement la suite de se tir de missile
de Pyongyang ce matin on les écoute
le tir de missile bellistique par la
Corée du Nord est un acte scandaleux et
absolument inadmissible
nous répondrons dès que possible avec la
plus grande vigilance
la Corée du Nord a une nouvelle fois
lancé un missile balistique de moyenne
portée
à environ 4000 km de l'archipel japonais
une telle provocation nucléaire
irresponsable se heurtera à une réponse
résolue de la part de nos militaires
ainsi que de nos alliés et de la
communauté internationale
Brice on a bien vu quand même discours
très ferme on sait que Séoul Tokyo et
Washington ont mené la semaine dernière
des exercices trilatéraux en tissous
marins pour la première fois en 5 ans
d'après ce que j'ai lu est-ce
qu'effectivement il y a un axe important
faire entre eux donc la Corée du Sud le
Japon et les États-Unis dans cette zone
alors cet axe existe effectivement il y
a quand même près de 30000 militaires
américains qui sont stationnés en
permanence
en Corée du Sud il y a des militaires
américains stationnés au Japon les
militaires américains patrouillent très
régulièrement en mer de Chine du Sud
enfin dans toute la zone donc il y a une
présence américaine mais j'ai été très
étonné ce matin quand on a commencé à
parler de ce qui s'était passé on a
présenté enfin beaucoup de médias on
présentait comme une riposte japonaise
le fait que deux F-15 était tiré des
bombes classiques des bombes de
précision certes mais des bombes
classiques sur un petit îlot c'est pas
une réponse militaire et on voit
difficilement il y a jamais eu de
réponse militaire à toutes les toutes
les actions toutes les essais qui ont
été faits par la Corée du Nord donc des
réponses sous forme de sanction ONU je
crois qu'on est arrivé au bout du bout
de ses sanctions et je vois
difficilement ce qui pourrait être fait
davantage contre la Corée du Nord donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire justement à
ce moment-là
dans l'environnement international je
pense qu'il faut rester un instant sur
l'environnement régional si j'ose dire
j'ai évoqué le cas de la Corée du Sud et
de son nouveau président je dirais dans
le cas du Japon il y a aussi une
évolution parce que pendant des années
le Japon a été disons a tenu des propos
qu'on qualifierait gentiment de
diplomatiques c'est-à-dire centraux
aussi l'autoron en espérant que le
dialogue permettrait de résoudre un
problème qui est extrêmement important
pour le Japon qui est qui est le
problème des ressortissants japonais
kidnappaient par la Corée du Nord au fil
des années disons des années 70 à la fin
à la fin du siècle dernier
l'apothéose de ça ça a été la visite de
Ko Izumi en 2002
et le retour de quelques personnes
depuis il y a un changement de ton et
notamment depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
AB en 2012 car AB avait un n'avait pas
confiance dans la Corée du Nord et ne
s'est pas engagé dans cette voie-là et
au contraire essayer de faire comprendre
au monde politique japonais et à
l'opinion publique il n'a pas
manifestement complètement réussi si on
en juge d'après les protestations qui
ont eu lieu la semaine dernière lors de
ces funérailles qu'il y avait un
véritable danger pour le pour le Japon
avec la Corée du Nord mais aussi
évidemment avec la Chine et le Japon
il y aura un plus grand alignement sur
les États-Unis et avec la présidence
nouvelle en Corée du Sud il y a un
rapprochement avec le nouveau
gouvernement il se trouve que les
relations entre monsieur Moon et
Monsieur abbé étaient exécrable monsieur
Kishida qui a été ministre des Affaires
étrangères avaient des meilleures
relations avec les dirigeants
sud-coréens notamment les les régions
conservateurs a connu lorsqu'il était
ministre et donc il y a une tentative de
rapprochement entre le Japon et la Corée
du Sud qui se manifeste par des je
dirais pour l'instant des discussions
extrêmement courtoises aux Nations unies
ou à Tokyo et aussi par la participation
à ces exercices militaires car souvent
ces exercices militaires c'était des
exercices Corée États-Unis avec des
Européens États-Unis Japon avec des
Européens mais rarement avec les Coréens
la Corée du Nord mais derrière également
la Chine il y a aussi des exercices qui
sont en train de se dérouler entre les
États-Unis le Japon et les Philippines
et qui vise là
ostensiblement la protection de Taïwan
voir le problème des îles du sud de la
mère de Chine du Sud Pierre-Antoine donc
on est vraiment dans une forme
d'escalade dans cette région aussi je ne
sais pas si c'est vraiment une escale en
tout cas c'est un moment de bascule ça
c'est très clair et pour reprendre ce
que vous disiez à l'instant monsieur
Colin je suis assez d'accord avec vous
l'arrivée au pouvoir de shinzoa B a été
un moment de vraiment
définitif d'un changement de politique
du Japon qui est devenue plus maître de
son destin et qui s'est affirmé comme un
véritable partenaire non pas agressif
mais en tout cas responsable et qui veut
désormais maintenant jouer un rôle sur
la scène asiatique en tenant en compte
de tout le passé évidemment épouvantable
de la colonisation de la péninsule
coréenne et de la Chine et le Japon oui
mais bien sûr de façon clair et net donc
il y a une course aux armements dans
cette aujourd'hui
le budget de la défense japonais n'a
jamais été aussi élevé depuis 1945 mais
pour revenir à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure et pour préciser un peu mon
propos vous savez le chantage nucléaire
caban dit bien sûr à plusieurs reprises
Vladimir Poutine c'est aussi le cas de
la Corée du Nord depuis qu'il possède
l'arme nucléaire et ça je pense que pour
les Chinois pour le gouvernement chinois
et pour le Parti communiste chinois ça
n'est pas acceptable et c'est une autre
raison pour laquelle
et que vous voulez
nous disions que il ne maîtrise pas qui
nous en nous et encore moins ça sa sœur
ils font selon ce qu'ils veulent et dans
leur tête vraiment il y a des moments où
on ne peut pas comprendre vous savez le
langage politique en Corée du Nord est
unique à la Corée du Nord moi j'ai été
une fois en 1986 je suis resté un peu
moins de deux semaines et je n'oublierai
jamais chaque seconde de ce séjour c'est
un univers totalement différent ou les
décisions sont prises elles nous
échappent c'est
l'imprévisibilité totale
et tout à l'heure on le disait c'est
leur dernier joker et c'est un régime
qui a qui est basé sur un ce que
j'appellerais un hyper nationalisme
c'est un nationalisme qui est né de la
guerre contre le Japon mais c'est aussi
un nationalisme qui se méfie de ce
puissant voisin qui est la Chine car le
Royaume de Corée était tributaire de
l'empire de Chine et donc les je dirais
ce sentiment il est extrêmement fort au
nord il est beaucoup moins fort au sud
pour des raisons qui sont principalement
économiques mais il n'est pas il n'est
pas absent non plus générale Bruxelles
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'étape d'après pour qui nous ont un
c'est un tir nucléaire
il est possible que ce soit un tiers
nucléaire ça serait dans la logique du
de ce système mais ça ne changera pas
grand chose on a déjà eu des tirs
nucléaires en particulier entre 2000 et
2016-2017 il y a eu plusieurs tiers
nucléaires les tirs sont un peu
indispensables pour les pays qui n'ont
pas de grands moyens pour pouvoir faire
de la simulation comme ça se fait
maintenant dans les pays comme la France
ou les États-Unis mais il y a quelque
chose aussi qui me paraît assez
important c'est que dans leur à l'heure
actuelle où on voit se monter ces
espèces de blocs antioxydantal le fait
que la Corée du Nord petit pays tout
seul sans aide extérieure énorme sans
excès invisible a réussi à se monter un
arsenal balistique et nucléaire et ça ça
fait rêver des pays comme l'Iran comme
l'Algérie un peu aussi le Brésil qui a
eu un programme nucléaire qu'il a
abandonné donc tout ça ça renforce un
petit peu
aussi occidentalisme dans le monde
entier et la Corée du Nord est pas si
isolée que ça dans l'esprit d'un certain
nombre de gens vous êtes d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit Jean-Yves Colin
ça renforce cette espèce de sentiment
antioxydantal je dirais que ça pour moi
la Corée du Nord reste quand même à un
pays isolé c'est quand même une sorte de
force forteresse assiégée qu'ils aient
j'allais dire qu'ils aient un regard un
peu bienveillant de la part d'un pays
prenant le cas du Brésil qui est qui est
dans un univers culturel complètement
différent c'est possible mais ça ne fera
pas bouger beaucoup le Brésil ou
d'autres pays en revanche la Corée du
Nord intéresse dans la mesure où c'est
une puissance militaire elle peut livrer
des armes elle peut livrer des armes
elle en livre donc à la Russie elle en
livre elle arrivera à Russie elle peut
en livrer à l'Iran elle peut en livrer à
l'Algérie et il y a là un intérêt je
dirais commercial aux militaire de la
Corée du Nord qu'elle sait dont elle
joue assez facilement parce qu'elle a
pas grand chose d'autre à vendre donc la
prochaine étape c'est le
une étape je dirais qui déclenche une
catastrophe absolue il y a déjà eu je
crois 7 et ces nucléaires de la Corée du
Nord dans le passé donc ça sera une
étape de plus sur la consiste
ça sera un étape de plus dans la
construction de l'arsenal nucléaire
nord-coréen la question c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est d'une sorte
d'impasse et comment faire pourquoi vous
dites que c'est une impasse aujourd'hui
on a testé le dialogue avec Corée du
Nord ça ne servit à rien sinon à donner
du temps à la Corée du Nord pour s'armer
on a étudié la fermeté mais on va jamais
jusqu'au bout comme le dit l'expert
militaire on ne on aurait poste pas avec
les armes on riposte avec des paroles ou
des sanctions
et aujourd'hui on ne sait pas très bien
quoi faire pour changer la Corée du Nord
qui elle n'a pas envie de changer
puisque la garantie de sa survie c'est
son arsenal nucléaire
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec cette
alliance pour les Chinois ennemis
du Nord également pour nous le royaume
ermite et le royaume-hermite la
signification c'est clair c'est qu'il
est tout seul
là ce qui manifeste c'est n'est pas dans
une grande solitude puisque les gêner
ses voisins les Japonais je vous assure
vous savez la Corée du Nord ne fait
rêver personne pour peu qu'on
s'intéresse surtout pas la Chine
c'est sa seule garantie de survie mais
ce que je voudrais rajouter c'est que
pour parler du Japon et de la présence
militaire américaine au Japon la base
aérienne de cadena et qui est donc à
okinaw comme je l'ai visité à deux
reprises quand j'étais au Japon de là
partent les avions espions américains
qui surveillaient en particulier la
Corée du Nord ils ont toutes les
capacités de savoir très exactement tout
ce qui se passe tous les préparatifs
donc s'il devait y avoir bien sûr il y
aura cet essai nucléaire le 7e ça c'est
une c'est une évidence c'est carrément
une certitude et c'est vrai que peu à
peu les missiles sont plus performants
le rayon d'action est beaucoup plus
efficace et maintenant c'était 6500 4500
km ça sera bientôt beaucoup plus et la
bombe nucléaire ils arrivent peu à peu
la miniaturiser donc ils seront un jour
effectivement en capacité de monter une
ogive nucléaire dans un missile pour
éventuellement éventuellement menacer le
territoire américain mais on en est très
loin et je vous assure que les
Américains en particulier leur président
Joe Biden ne le permettront jamais
général oui ça vous êtes d'accord en
fait avec ce que vient de dire
Pierre-Antoine Denain ils sont loin
justement de menacer directement le
territoire américain le nord-coréen
Kim Jong-un alors le problème de la
dissuasion de la dissuasion nucléaire du
faible haut fort et du Fou au fort et
que ils en sont peut-être loin ils en
sont peut-être pas si loin que ça parce
que ils ont déjà fait des bricolages
pour tirer un exemplaire d'un missile et
il suffit en terme de nucléaire on sait
qu'il peut fabriquer quelque chose dont
la fiabilité n'est pas garantie du tout
mais qui est qui aurait la capacité dans
à mon avis quelques mois quelques années
mais assez proche capable d'aller
jusqu'à au territoire américain
[Musique]
sans aucune précision tant pis ça le
simple fait qu'une arme nucléaire
explose sur le territoire américain ça
serait largement suffisant pour changer
un peu la donne vis-à-vis de la Corée du
Nord vis-à-vis des États-Unis ils en
sont bientôt capables vous dites
je pense il y a une tentative de
lancement d'un satellite c'était on a eu
on a fini par avoir il y a eu des vidéos
qui ont été diffusées par les
Nord-Coréens on a fini par comprendre à
peu près en analysant un certain nombre
de choses comment avait été fabriqué ce
lanceur de satellite c'est quelque chose
de totalement
chez les bricolage évolué mais c'est
quand même ça relève du bricolage par
rapport à ce qu'on fait dans les dans
les autres pays au point de vue spatial
mais c'est quelque chose qui est une
portée énorme et c'est capable d'emmener
une charge de quelques centaines de
kilos et les Nord-Coréens sont
parfaitement capables de fabriquer une
arme nucléaire de quelques centaines de
kilos et à ce moment-là ils ont la
portée pour une fois pour un tir alors
il y aurait des préparatifs ce sont des
missiles qu'on est obligé de tirer à
l'air libre et les satellites américains
les avions de reconnaissance américaine
le verrai immédiatement les préparatifs
maintenant est-ce que les États-Unis
pourraient se permettre une frappe
préventive pour détruire ce missile sur
le investir avant qu'il soit lancé c'est
une grosse question pour le moment ils
ont jamais fait ça et faire ça ça serait
repasser du côté des agresseurs c'est
vraiment très difficile à gérer c'est
très difficile à gérer vous êtes
d'accord parce qu'on parle ce changement
de stratégie peut-être d'avoir une
capacité préventive la question qui se
pose c'est comment trouver une piste de
dialogue un peu près confiant ce qui est
quand même bien difficile avec la Corée
du Nord entre d'une part
l'acceptation par les États-Unis au
premier chef et par les autres
puissances mais aux États-Unis par le
premier chef de la réalité qui est que
on empêchera pas la Corée du Nord d'être
une puissance nucléaire elle l'est et
elle ne l'abandonnera pas et d'autre
part faire entrer quand même la Corée du
Nord dans un processus disons de
dénucléarisation progressive étape par
étape contrôler c'était le but des
négociations qui avaient été engagé à
l'époque Clinton qui était pas loin
d'aboutir mais dans mais qui ont ensuite
n'aboutit pas goûté avec Clinton ça n'a
pas abouti avec moi je pense que la
Corée du Nord vit dans un état de dans
une mentalité de forteresse assiégée que
le pouvoir en Corée du Nord est
uniquement assis sur cette puissance que
la Corée du Nord n'est certainement pas
non plus bien qu'on ne le sache pas très
bien un pouvoir totalement homogène il y
a des il y a des peut-être des factions
des rivalités au niveau de l'armée on ne
sait pas mais il faut trouver ce
cheminement sinon le risque est
effectivement c'est qu'un jour il y a un
je dirais il y a un coup de sang de l'un
ou de l'autre peut-être plus de Kim que
des États-Unis mais on peut on ne peut
pas le négliger
comment pourrait-elle reprendre on a vu
qu'elles avaient capoté donc du temps de
Trump on voit qu'on n'est pas du tout
dans un à une période de négociation
pessimiste si non plus on a beaucoup
parlé
le dialogue effectivement sous la
déclinerations de la péninsule coréenne
ça fait très longtemps que ça existe et
ça n'aboutira à mon avis pas avant très
longtemps si tentait que ça aboutisse un
jour mais réunification encore moins
encore moins encore moins mais ça c'est
absolument exclu pour le moment mais
je voudrais dire deux choses la première
c'est que le seul effort considérable de
la de l'industrie de l'économie
nord-coréenne se porte sur le militaire
au détriment évidemment de toute la
population qui on sait bien vit dans des
conditions absolument épouvantables on
le sait bien ce qu'on le sait vraiment
parce que
différentes manières il y a des
indicateurs économiques qui montrent
qu'effectivement parce qu'il y a une
produit au-delà des indicateurs
économiques il y a quand même des
visites il y a des ONG sur place
qu'évidemment sont étroitement
surveillés elles ne font pas ce qu'elles
veulent mais elles voient quand même la
réalité
nord-coréenne d'autre part il y a une
famine par exemple en Corée du Nord une
famille depuis déjà longtemps alors il
sont mis en prison pour leur restant de
leur jour mais ceux qui arrivent en
Corée du Sud aux États-Unis au
Royaume-Uni ou dans notre pays en Asie
il parle et leur témoignages est
absolument mais et pouvant table sur ce
qu'est la Corée du Nord aujourd'hui et
sur le degré de résistance de la
population qui n'irait par n'existe pas
mais qui est tué dans le partout où il y
a une tentative c'est un pays plus que
totalitaire c'est pire qu'un despotisme
c'est un régime tyrannique tyrannique
dans le dernier degré et face à cela
effectivement si d'aventure un jour Kim
Jong-un ou sa soeur ou peut-être son
successeur s'il en a ce que je ne pense
pas vous pensez c'est le dernier des
clim vous savez on en est encore très
loin parce qu'il est jeune qui mais bon
beaucoup de scénarios sont possibles on
va pas lire dans les cartes unies dans
le marc de café mais ce que je voulais
dire si avant tout d'aventure un jour
Kim Jong-un décide de balancer une bombe
mais ce serait un suicide ce sera la fin
de son régime c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il ne le fera pas général Brisset
vous êtes d'accord sur ce point parce
que manifestement on n'est pas au moment
des négociations en ce moment en tout
cas dans la péninsule on est plutôt dans
une escalade ça sera un suicide pour
qu'ils nous ont une si effectivement il
utilisait un de ses missiles nucléaire
alors je ne sais pas dans la mesure où
quand même Kim Jong-un comme son père
comme son grand-père se présente
vis-à-vis de sa population comme l'homme
qui leur permet de résister et qui leur
permet de vivre beaucoup moins mal que
ce qu'on que ce que ça pourrait être
s'il n'était pas là ils sont les pertes
tutélaires de les trois sont les pertes
titulaires de la nation et je pense que
l'immense majorité de la population
subit les souffrances qu'elle subit qui
sont tout à fait réels en particulier
ces problèmes de famine qui vont et qui
viennent mais ils sont en absence totale
d'information dans l'extérieur je pense
que la population comme l’était la
population de l'URSS à une certaine
époque comme l'était la population
chinoise complètement privé
d'information sont persuadés que ça va
encore plus mal à l'extérieur et que
finalement
le grand le Grand Timonier fait le de
son mieux et ce qui fait c'est pas mal
et que il fait peur aux États-Unis il
fait peur à tous ces pays où il se passe
des horreurs et que finalement c'est pas
si mal que ça donc je sais pas si on se
retrouve dans une logique suicidaire de
la part de Kim Jong-un je pense que la
logique est une logique très
particulière à ce pays et que ça n'a
rien à voir avec nos méthodes cela n'a
rien à voir nos manières de penser et
surtout ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'ouverture que nous avons vers
l'extérieur que non absolument pas les
Coréens alors savoir avec quoi
moi je pense que pour reprendre le titre
de votre émission que Kim Jong est un en
effet incontrôlable mais il n'est pas
dénué de rationalité donc c'est sur
cette rationalité qu'il faut parier à la
fois pour ces choses-là qu'il reste
raisonnable dans ces gesticulations
militaires et pour que un moment le bon
sens revienne dans cette affaire et
qu'il retrouve le chemin d'une table de
négociation c'est pas le moment
peut-être parce que j'ai été diplomate
dans mon passé donc je crois
effectivement au dialogue diplomatique
mais je dirais je pense que c'est
possible il faut pas du tout l'exclure
c'est évidemment pas le moment
actuellement et c'est encore moins le
moment à cause de ce contexte
international qu'on connaît je dirais
tant qu'on connaîtra pas la fin de
l'histoire
ukrainienne si on la connaît il y aura
pas de tellement de possibilités et de
toute façon le dialogue prendra du temps
je dirais en ça on peut presque
regretter que la tentative de Trump a
échoué parce que Tru avec son côté de
négociateur de l'immobilier qui cherche
à faire des deals un peu mon enfant il
avait pénible il avait probablement
trouvé une piste le problème je dirais
que c'est que de son côté il a peut-être
pas beaucoup travaillé son dossier quand
il est quand il est allé et donc ça
ennuie à l'avancement le deal le deal a
échoué et le deal a échoué
je rejoins un peu ce que vous dites
effectivement j'espère qu'un jour il y
aura une place pour la négociation et
pour l'ouverture d'une table ou se
mettre ensemble pour discuter de ce qui
va se passer plus tard c'est la seule
formule pour survivre si on réfléchit
bien pour qu'il met en route parce que
il voit bien que peu à peu c'est
encerclement il se précise de jour en
jour parce que bien sûr il y a le Japon
bien sûr surtout il y a les États-Unis
maintenant il y a aussi un peu la Chine
qui est en train de réfléchir à ce
qu'elle peut faire avec la Corée du Nord
la Russie aussi hésite et l'État voyou
on voit bien le
le nucléaire de l'Iran elle a été rendue
possible en partie grâce à l'aide des
scientifiques nord-coréens ils sont
extrêmement surveillés d'ailleurs par
les Américains l'Iran en ce moment donc
voilà la marge de manœuvre est
extrêmement étroite pour qu'ils ont un
comme vous le dites je pense qu'il y a
quand même un fond de rationalité dans
son cerveau général Brisset pour
conclure un fond de rationalité tout de
même chez Kim Jong-un
c'est un régime qui dure depuis 70 ans
c'est une dynastie qui dure depuis 70
ans avec des une collection d'exactions
une collection de d'anomalies par
rapport à nos systèmes de fonctionnement
absolument extraordinaires et il y a eu
une période c'est comme le disait
monsieur Colin une petite période ça a
failli marcher c'est entre Trump a étalé
dans le bras de fer était rentré dedans
a été extrêmement brutal a obtenu des
choses en étant très brutal avec la
Chine en particulier
ça ça a failli marcher je sais pas si
c'est un problème de Trump lui-même ou
si c'est un problème lié à l'opposition
avec contre toute négociation venant de
l'intérieur même des États-Unis en
attendant il y a on l'a vu il y a une
possibilité et la rationalité qui me
jong-uns sa volonté de survivre passe
peut-être effectivement par des
négociations mais ça sera encore sans
doute avec des coups d'éclat avant merci
beaucoup général sur Vincent d'avoir été
avec nous en direct de Bruxelles merci
beaucoup Jean-Yves Colin et puis merci à
vous et Antoine Donnet merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi vous restez avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]